this is a production of Cornell
University
good afternoon I'm gonna be talking
about soil health in India and don't you
know nothing about India because I will
cover some of that as I go through this
presentation I also interspersed this
with quotes both in the anglicized
version of Hindi and the English
translation just to tell you what Indian
people think about soil as you go
through this is if we got went to my
presentation like I said I'll give you
the background of India as well as soil
health in general the way I'm looking at
it and the comprehensive assessment of
soil health which was developed here at
Cornell actually that is Cornell there
goes through some of the objectives the
methodology for my three objectives and
I'll end with some preliminary results
most of which is all all which is on my
objective one right now so I don't have
too much represent to you okay quick
background this is India if you haven't
seen the map of India yet the yellow is
arable land so what of yellows a lot of
forest green and the total area of 328
million hectares of the country of which
60% is agricultural land offset 60%
about another 60% it's rain fed
agriculture
so most definian agriculture can assume
is rain fed is small holes or farms less
than two hectares and yet despite all
that India has a pretty much equal
export import when it comes cyber
cultural produce so there's some stuff
that we import others that we export but
as net we are pretty food
self-sufficient so the quickness thing
into Indian cropping systems we actually
have two to three cropping systems here
like the u.s. so you have a carve
cropping season which is usually in the
monsoons across the country so June to
October and there you'll have rice
obviously again monsoons corn cotton all
of which is grown in this season then
you have a dry season crop which is
Robbie and then that you have wheat
barley mustard a lot of the pulses are
grown at this time and some farmers will
try squeeze in
summer crop in between March to June and
that's usually melons and boards and
other short season crops okay so getting
into the meat if it's oils this is a
soil map of India the yellow is alpha
Seoul so a lot of alpha Sol's West has a
lot of vertosols as well but where I'm
focused is up over here which is the
Northeast and there there is mostly in
septa Sol's and anta Sol's looking even
further at an actual map of the state
which is Baha'i this is northeast corner
so you have Nepal up here Bangladesh
there's a state of chakra and below
where someone else in lab phil frost has
also done a lot of research and this
state the interesting thing is it's
bifurcated right in the middle by the
Ganga
so the Ganga cuts through the state and
generally how I propose works there is
these are mostly young alluvial soils
and a lot of nutrients that are coming
with the river generally flood the local
area slightly and then there's a like
renewal of nutrients almost every year
because of this it also leads to
excessive flooding especially in recent
years so that's definitely something
that cause a lot of risk in agriculture
in that area where we are is this little
right above the river this little purple
area which is actually calcareous so a
lot of the work that a lot of soils and
I'm working with are calcareous as well
okay here's a better picture of the
state itself beha the total population
of the state is 99 million that's more
than a lot of countries in Europe
including the UK Germany France all of
them are smaller than that and close to
80 percent off this 99 million all work
in agriculture so Bihar is inherently
rural and on a lot of developmental
indexes in India Falls towards the lower
side of the categories they mostly grow
wheat rice wheat and maize there is a
lot of vegetables that are produced in
the country even though they're not
considered the primary production and it
also has lowest farm income in the
country which is always interesting to
men
in general in India farming is not a
lucrative career it's about ninety five
dollars a month you would get from
farming but in Bihar it's less than half
of the national average so it's just
it's inherently very poor estate
so that's where soil health comes into
play
soil health generally also refer to soil
quality by the NRCS is defined as the
capacity of the soil to function as a
living ecosystem in our case that
generally involves sustaining plants or
food production it has a number of
functions that we try define as
important to that functioning of the
soil and the US especially a lot of the
waste oil health has been seen is
looking at the physical chemical and
biological processes also in India it's
slowly starting to be seen that way but
for a lot of government policy soil
health is still considered mostly just
chemical processes so the soil health
credit scheme for example which has been
currently run by the government and it's
costing the government eighty six
million dollars looks at just nitrogen
phosphorus and potassium all farmer
soils and micronutrients and considers
that a complete picture of soil health
so why soil health I mean a big reason
is because India is gonna face a soil
crisis soon and all of South Asia what
we're seeing is that you'll have to come
from increasing production because all
of land that could possibly put it under
agriculture is already under agriculture
get a lot of the soils that we have
currently are degraded which is leading
to either decrease or stagnating yields
so improving soil quality can be a
really important way for us to improve
those skills and the reason I'm using
the comprehensive assessment of soil
health to look at this is it was
developed at Cornell
it's been tested over the years in a
multi multiple different scenarios it's
a very comprehensive approach that looks
at physical chemical and biological
processes of soil health and it's been
tested thoroughly and the way just as a
conceptual view of how this came about
is we have soil services say for example
for production which is what I'm really
looking at and that's a result of
certain soil functions that the soil
does like plant growth function themself
is influenced by the soil processes that
are leading to these functions and since
we can't measure soil processes we're
gonna look at indicators that will give
us an idea of how these processes work
or how these processes are progressing
so that comes up with a soil health test
that we've tried to create which looks
at all three different processes that
fall under the three different factors
want to point out that this is also kind
of a feedback loops if you have a soil
health test that gives you
recommendations you you continuously
like test for this your indicators get
better that is influencing your
processes that will eventually influence
your soil service as well
okay so the cash indicators I'm going to
get into what indicators that we're
going to be measuring but just as a
quick up quick aside the way these cash
indicators were selected was one the
relevance of that specific indicator to
the processes that we want to look at
how can we how consistently can we
reproduce it in the lab how easy is it
to sample and what is the cost so
putting all that together we came up
with 15 um
tests and I'll kind of go over all of
them specifically there's the chemical
tests which is soil pH organic matter
extractable pnk micronutrients this is
kind of commonly known and it's what
India normally does for the soil health
card the biological tests are active
carbon soil respiration and a protein
test and then for the physical
characteristics we look at aggregate
stability available water capacity and
surface and subsurface hardness and it's
kind of an example you have one of the
final analyses that we do if a 10-page
reports this is the top page you have
your physical characteristics your
biological up over here and then your
chemical and you have the value that you
calculate in the lab whatever the units
are and each of these values are then
converted to a rating that I'll explain
how we get in a little while which is
kind of on a sliding scale so it goes
from 0 to 100
obviously if everything is great you get
a little green rating goes up to 100 if
for any reason your score is very low it
got maybe a red and it's worse lower
side and then eventually you have an
overall score which is an unweighted me
off all our indexes and we also keep
texture into mine because obviously all
of these indicators are going to be
affected by textures that kind of will
change how our rating is taken the
rating can have it you can have three
different kinds of ratings there's one
which is more is better so it's
generally a sliding scale up over here
is active carbon as an example so more
buttons higher the value of active
carbon the better it is there's some
where lowers
better so surface hardness for examples
obviously too hard for soil is bad and
then there's some that's an optimum
value so pH where you want it to be
neither high in our low
and how we convert the raw score into an
actual rating is we have a normative
evaluation so you have you're comparing
each sample that you analyze and lab to
a larger population of samples and all
this population of samples has been like
you had you put up a histogram you have
all your samples in place they're mostly
all normally distributed so you have a
mean and a standard deviation that you
get from that and then you convert that
to a cumulative normal distribution oh
one thing that's really important all
the samples that were used to define our
current distribution function have all
been taken in the US and that is going
to affect the rating because as I don't
wanna lay Doral OTT of this like values
that I've gotten in India a lot of
values that other people have gotten in
India are all on the lower side of what
you would consider here what you would
find here in the US so it till it's low
like it sways the function and it sways
the rating and that needs to be
reanalyzed
yeah getting into my objectives of what
I want to do with the study so I want to
know what effect soil health and I want
to know how he measure it accurately and
efficiently so the first objective which
as I said what I've really started and
I've gotten the results on is I want to
look at the effect of different crop
management techniques on soil health
what I will be getting into is assessing
soul quality indicators using
mid-infrared reflection spectroscopy as
well as developing an infield test for
some basic cell quality measurements
I'll guarantee you should be as little
in a second the first objective the
study sites that I've mostly focused on
so far is first the dolphin watch and
Prasad Central Agricultural University
so this is a university that I'm being
hosted at that I'm working at while in
India it's located in South Yarra like I
showed you in my stapler
it's it was established in 1905 actually
so is it originally a British Imperial
College for agriculture which after
independence was renamed to the current
Rajendra Prasad Central Agricultural
University after the first president in
fact and the second place that I've
taken samples currently is at the cereal
systems initiative for South Asia so
this is under C cell which is sorry this
is under simit which is the
International amazing wheat Research
Institute they also work in
collaboration with the Rice Research
Institute and if pre which is the
policy research and student I'm
forgetting what if stands for his moment
okay
no Bella sigh sigh it's one of the first
things that we had to do was actually
create a lot was set up a lab and given
like I said a lot of testing in India
for soils is mostly on the chemical side
a lot of the equipment that I would need
for the biological and physical
indicators were in present so it was one
of the first goals of the project I
spent like the first year creating this
lab with the University and it's a
little tricky because you can't ship
soils from India to the US so we
couldn't just analyze them over here but
it's also hard creating a lab there
because there are some restrictions I'm
just transferring foreign funds to India
as well so that was a very challenging
process but has been very fulfilling
given that it's all come together now
yeah this is the methodology for how I'm
gonna get into my objectives the first
part like I said that I have started
working on is can we pick up significant
effects of management techniques on
these long from these long-term trials
I've ant like already sampled trials at
the University at FISA I'm looking at
prologue Institute of South Asia which
also has a lot of long term trials with
a lot of like legacy data one of the
things I'm hoping to do soon after is he
says also collecting projects from
around the state as well and that
analyzing those samples will also give
me an idea of the differences between
University plots and farmer fields and
so you can see which of these practices
are actually being adopted which of them
are showing actual health benefits and
that kind of leads us and who will
hopefully be building diverse and
resilient systems and the experiments
that I'm working on and I'll come back
to this as I get into my results is
mostly looking at cropping patterns
organic amendments and so you'll notice
same comes up twice that's because a lot
of these soils are zinc deficient so
that's one of the things that a lot of
the University trials are studying and
also looking at for different scenarios
at the SI subplots going from farmer
fields to diversified systems okay
flavors day they're with me the second
objective that I'm looking at it saying
cell quality indicators using my
reflection spectroscopy this has been
done before on a number of indicators by
a number of different scientists and the
results varies there are certain
indicators like clay content or carbon
that have actually predicted very well
using reflection spectroscopy there are
a lot of indicators where we're not
seeing any relation between the
spectroscopy data and the actual
indicator values so I'm really
interested in seeing all the 50
indicators I have chosen what are some
of the conclusions we can make and the
way this works is you have a sample
collection your own reflection
spectroscopy on all those samples you
analyze all those same samples in the
lab then you drive a model and
when the color models used is a partial
least squares regression model and then
so the next collection now that you have
a model set up you only you can analyze
95% of your samples using the reflection
spectroscopy you made infrared and then
you have a model to derive your soil
health indicators from that data so this
project again we're working with sea
sand the University and they're already
about a thousand samples collected that
we will be working on the third
objective is working with MIT to develop
a point of views and I'm sorry this is a
little hard to read I realize the lights
on so working with MIT to develop a
point of views NPK sensor and so they're
currently working on a sensor that will
measure just the nitrogen phosphorus and
potassium they want where we're gonna be
checking is an in lab accuracy as well
as in field accuracy Slyke both one once
the sensor is made how will that be how
does that compare to soil tests in the
lab and if it does work in the lab once
we take it out in the field how accurate
our adaptable is it and this is kind of
from their data what you have is a
little sensor up over here you have your
extract and soil it makes the soil and
the extractant and put the sensor in and
that will give you a value that you can
then take to an NP or a cave amount in
addition to that in terms of like adding
some information on the other
characteristics like the soil health
information Oh Josephus le who's sitting
over here has done some work on the best
subset analysis and the way that works
is you're trying to find out first if
you have a subset size of one what is
the one indicator that will best predict
your soil health value then what are the
top two indicators that will predict
your soil health value and finally the
top three indicators that will predict
your soil health value and in the end
the top three indicators are all the
same it's organic matter respiration and
active carbon but interestingly well in
the US samples of eight thousand samples
analyzed active carbon is the best
predictor of the soil health the final
soil health value the mean whereas in
India based on Phil Frost's data the
organic matter is actually top indicator
soil house the reason we're interested
in this is because active carbon is
actually a test that's fairly easy to
add to any infield test it can be done
around the field
itself it's easy it's inexpensive so if
we were to add one thing that would be
able to also give us a soil health value
along with the NPK data active carbon is
a very good candidate so that's one of
the reasons we're interested in having
some more data from India all right
hopefully everyone's doing good so far
okay uh I'm gonna get into some of the
preliminary results now um this has all
just been recently analyzed I've been
getting data this week itself so this is
still very rough but it's the first
experiment that we're looking at is
again the suspect of different cropping
patterns and management practices on the
seals as well oh so they have two
different crop rotations you have rice
sweet sorghum that's more typical off
the state they're all grasses and then
the other is rice mustard Moonbeam so
Moonbeam is a legume it's a little more
of a diverse system and on top of that
there are four subplots or four
treatments you're looking at ten
kilograms ink such as zinc then you have
ten tonnes of farm here in many are
which I'm going to use as fym I'm going
to have combinations so ten kilograms
saying five sunflower manure and
kilogram saying and what we're gonna
find is this is our graph up over here
this first off is looking at active
carbon the purple is the rice sweet
sorghum the blue is the rice mustard
Moonbeam and the way I've set this up is
I've got farmer Ben you're up over here
there's no control as you'll notice so
this is the study was set up actually in
1985 so it's been a couple of decades
which is really great in terms of amount
of data we have available but one of the
issues is the way was set up then and
has continued means you can't really
change it in between without losing some
of that legacy data so we've compromised
by using a tent on FIM that's zero
kilograms of zinc and I'm saying plenty
of editions of FYM so it goes up like
that and
we have active carbon up here on the
y-axis and what you're seeing is one the
average rice sweet sorghum active carbon
is higher than for the legume rice
mustard Moonbeam system that's really
interesting it's also not a perfect
comparison because these aren't
randomized between systems so you have
system a which has the four treatments
randomized within and then you have
system B which has the four treatments
randomized within so we can't fully tell
because the way this is set up if the
difference is that we're seeing are due
to the cropping systems are just spatial
differences without doing maybe some
more further research but some of the
preliminary data that we're seeing we're
also seeing is in terms of the actual
treatments there's no differences in the
rice mustard Moonbeam which is the blue
up over here but we do see some slight
we do see differences between the rice
wheat sorghum where you can see the
addition all farmer manure is increasing
the active carbon
all right well we are seeing is well
protein we should take a similar trend
actually so there's no difference again
in the rice mustard Moonbeam still in
blue but we are seeing the increase in
the rice sweet sorghum up over here
which is interesting because again like
I said Moonbeam is a linked you but
we're not seeing an effect on soil
protein I should also mention while I'm
on this slide the samples were taken
before the rice was planted when the
fields and the Moonbeam had been
harvested when they're like filled with
fallows so this is after it's a third
planting and before the next planting of
rice is when these samples have been
taken alright getting into this is my
same graph so we will skip it okay we're
seeing address stability so one of the
things this is the only physical
characteristic that we were able to
measure so far given some of the data
we're collecting and aggregate stability
is up here in y-axis that's percent
stable aggregates and again blue is
still rice mustard Moonbeam purple is
rice sweet sorghum and we're not
actually seeing any differences between
these plots and these are all fairly
small plots so maybe that isn't only
understandable you know we're not seeing
much effect of either of this
okay experiment 2 is looking at organic
crop residues and inorganic fertilizers
and rice wheat systems do you have for
organic fertilizers which is know in
your farmyard manure crop residue and a
combination of crop residue in farmyard
manure and then you have for fertilizer
treatment fortaleza treatments which is
zero fifty hundred and one hundred and
fifty percent of the recommended rates
and the first thing we're seeing is that
there is no effect of fertilizer or
organic amendments inactive carbon there
appears to be a trend going from no mean
you're up to farmyard manure in the
means of these treatments but they're
not significant
in addition to but when you're looking
at soil protein we're now seeing the
same differences again no manure is yeah
there you see the same trends so soil
protein going up from no manure systems
up to from your manure and crop residue
systems and you can tell us like up here
it's mostly CDs and then up over here
there is there is a clear difference
we're not seeing a lot of difference of
the recommended fertilizer rate though
so again in some places there is that
expected as you increase fertilizer soil
protein is going up a little but that's
not consistently true
above here farmer urine crop residue the
means show greater aspiration so if you
look at a mean of no many are from ever
in your crop residue these three aren't
particularly different but the farmyard
manure plus propers do you mean is
different but we're not seeing
differences again within each treatment
for aspiration and again we're not think
significant difference is an aggregate
ability instability so that's going to
be true of all the experiments that I
look at and one of the reasons I could
be and I forgot to mention this in the
first experiment is all three
experiments are aggressively tools so
whether that's incorporating the crop
residue or planting they're all tilled
aggressively so any effect that you
might see off these treatments and
aggregate stability is probably all
mitigated by the tilling okay the final
experiment in the university plots is a
long-term study on crop residue in sync
application this time we have four
organic amendments which is again zero
percent crop residue incorporation
twenty five fifty and then a hundred
percent reference to incorporation and
then looking at for treatments of zinc
which varies from zero to ten kilograms
per hectare
okay so um looking at active carbon
again or labile carbon what we are
seeing is that interestingly with the 0%
crop residues and zero sync what you
would imagine would be the lowest
wouldn't blow is fertile soils actually
shows one of the highest active carbons
so the 0% crop residue actually goes
from high to continuously low oh but
beyond that you do again see the same
trend of going up crop as you go up the
crop residue level increases your active
carbon also increases slightly
oh and the same trend in soil protein
again though this time without the
oddness and the 0% crop residue your
little so you see that trend going up
from VC to up over eight over here
respiration values we see a same trend
but not a significant difference in this
one at a time okay and I would get
stability again we're not seeing some of
the same differences we're not seeing
the differences that we weren't
expecting
okay so getting an experiment for which
is the one in the Patna Platz there are
four different scenarios to this the
scenario one is general farmer practices
so this is what farmers are doing in
that area itself so it's rice
conventionally tilled wheat
conventionally tilled and the third
season left fallow scenario to is the
best management practice so like just
slightly tweaking the systems you have
rice conventionally tilled still you
make weed zero tilt and you add Moonbeam
which leg you to the system scenario 3
is deal with water scarcity so in terms
so to aid with water conservation rice
wheat and Moonbeam are all 0 tools now
and that also aids with labour as well
because that's a big issue in the stage
in scenario 4 which is a more
intensified diversify system that might
take a little while to get to is you
arise 0 tilled mustard cereals and a
spring maize that's your child and
looking at the four scenarios what we
actually see is that the best management
practices have the highest active carbon
and the best managed practice again is
like the rice conventionally tilled weed
zero tilt and Moonbeam conventionally
tills which is tied in first place
actually for the water conservation
that's where rice wheat moonbeam are all
which is good news in terms of trying to
move people away from the more
conventional I tell our practice we also
see that same trend in a little protein
though this time the variability was
higher and we weren't able to find a
significant difference with soil
respiration what we see is again the
best management practices really will as
here does the intensified and
diversified systems and for our
practices this is slightly interesting
one of the issues with respiration in
India is also it's really hard to get a
consistent temperature because while
over here all our labs are temperature
control that's not
of India so respiration data is variable
throughout this experiment that is
tricky alright so coming up into some
conclusions we do see some of the
expected trends that we were expecting
in soil health in like looking at the
soil health data
there are also some stuff that we're not
really that wasn't expected and we can't
explain just yet
that's laden by the fact by a lot of
this is still preliminary data so we're
still getting an information on fuels
management health data
we're still getting information on yield
and once we have all of that that should
give us a better picture of what we're
seeing because we can correlate it with
lab results and so that I'll be spending
actually the next eight months call it
starting from our June to the beginning
of next semester and India collecting
and analyzing more data so let's think
Harold's up over here my committee
Andy's up over here as well
Prabhu Bengali Ranjan like is the
professor who works at boosah and has
been helping with my research a lot Bob
in the karela
but up in this well health team is
incredibly helpful with their data and
the results Santosh has been working in
India analyzing some of this data and
Zak also the soil health team has been
really helpful this is actually as in
India doing the soil health workshop
last summer where we're going over some
of these same indicators and thank you
[Applause]
hey I rushed through there's a lot of
time for questions yeah absolutely
so um most of these are actually right
suite systems because that's what's most
common in beha and the rice is generally
sown the minute the monsoon hits so it's
a bit of a varying time summer I
collected these they were collected in
the first week of July because the rains
actually hit later that year and we were
trying to get it with the first rain and
hits the ground wasn't too hard to
sample but before obviously rained
announce that people will start planting
the rice that's what we were aiming for
just because that's the best time for us
to be able to get the sample out of the
fields as well and also we won't have
any interference with the crop and the
soils were taken 0 to 15 centimetres 0
to 15 yeah so for actually the Buckner
plots they were just taken with a shovel
composite of 10 samples from the field
and then they were all mixed them
together and created it with one sample
the Pusa fields are actually like the
plots are much tinier so we weren't able
to get like a shovel and go in there cuz
your field is only about as big as this
so those were more taking with troubles
they were still a composite of 10
samples around the field so it's like in
W pattern that we go through that it's
fair question ok one of the reasons this
mustard is grown a lot in the area as
well more as a cash crop the more
physiological reasons a mustard I
actually am not sure about that's
something that I'd have to look into
more but the reason that a lot of our
university plows look at it is because
they use mustard for mustard oil so they
use the seeds for oil and it's a very
common crash problem there
so I actually didn't have error bars and
in there at the last minute I took them
out just because I was trying to keep
the data as simple as possible for
everyone oh the respiration they died
like I said has been the one that's most
variable and the reason for that is we
try you're using respiration as a
methodology for each indicator but we're
using an electrical conductivity meter
to be able to then calculate respiration
and it's kind of calibrated to a
specific temperature and in India it's
impossible to keep anything at a
specific temperature because there's a
day where it's like starts off that leg
zero and then goes up to like 30 degrees
right and that is something that we're
working with really we're taking just
the actual case heat koh data every day
and like trying to come up with how we
adjust that and that so right now this
is not adjusted data in any way this is
just the data that I thought I am
looking at being able to adjust the data
compared to temperature
that wasn't the respiration right so for
the first experiment that I did at the
University plot that's four treatments
and six reps and for the others there
are three reps each for eight treatments
yeah so well there are a couple of
reasons with the University plot one of
them is just it's a very small plot like
these are tiny paws that generally we
would be like you have to have bigger
because the Y's are just gonna get like
spillover effect from the plot that's
right next to you is one of the issues
that I think we'd be seeing three is
also just a small number obviously
having more than three reps is better to
decrease variability
yeah there's just some of the big things
in terms of why I would have seen
desirability
yes I am person yeah no that's really
interesting thank you so there's
actually two parts of the project that
I'm like very interested in but have
done no review on so that's why I do
want to put it up in the presentation
but one of that is looking at nutrient
flows across the state and so that's
something where I'm like are we
exporting crop residue where is the
carbon and nitrogen flowing within the
state itself and then maybe the country
and the second part is can we then take
the soil health indicator and turn it
into an economic benefit whether for
application and insurance insurance
scheme or for application in like
valuing the land but just being able to
say if my soil health indicator is this
much that's an economic benefit off this
much to the land itself to the farmer
those are both things that I'm
interested in but it's still like very
much the information gathering stage so
while I would like to do that I have no
idea if it's going to be possible
you have ideas please let me know I
think up over here so the first
experiment is 1985 the others are also
1980s but the exact date are skipping me
so the Pusa plots are a couple of
decades old the fisa plot is 2010 about
8 years so if I'm kind of that correctly
movie I do not have guilty that yet so
that's one of the things where I was
mentioning and hoping to get so the
yields a tie exists it's just actually
getting the yield either because again
like I said the plots gone through
multiple professors so the status is
kind of spread around the place and
you've been getting like last year's the
old data is like a bit of a process so
I'm hoping to get that and then being
able to correlate some of this
information else thing will be really
helpful and like progress to your trials
where I'm like well how much of the
prophecy was actually going back into
the yeah sorry I said again yeah I'm
really interested on that too I think
just from hearsay the plots with zero
sync are showing it you'll decrease and
you can kind of in one of the pictures
just see the little patchiness of the
soil and I'll get there eventually
oh but yeah so you do see patches in the
soil and you can just kind of estimate
you'll data that way but actually you'll
see I don't have yet
yes sorry so for a lot of smallholder
farmers manure is actually one of the
main ways that they fertilize so because
there is a lot more of the integrated
livestock approach in India you have
usually cows that people will keep for
dairy and the manure has to go somewhere
so it's either used for fuel or it's
used for manure in a lot of cases
there's also a lot of fertilizer
application because fertilizer is
subsidized in India but which is why
there's an experiment looking at both
organic amendment and fertilizer so yeah
I would say tun tun I mean I don't have
actual farmer data yet it's like I don't
know how much they would be applying but
I would say it's reasonable yeah right
yes those foreign functions were not
changed yeah I just try them to look
what else well so the best analysis none
of that is my data that's all Phil's
data from Phil's publication so as far
as I know it'll be how I can correct me
this was the scoring function was not
edited and that's just what he got from
there
[Laughter]
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu